Esta es la avenida Bless gianni en el
centro de Dakar aquí se encuentra el
mayor mercado de medicamentos
falsificados de la capital un negocio
que está creciendo las falsificaciones
están a la vista de todos bajo el sol en
las aceras las cámaras no son
bienvenidas Así que filmamos a
escondidas
presidente del sindicato de
farmacéuticos privados de senegal conoce
el peligro que representan los
medicamentos falsificados le llevamos
los artículos que compramos en el
mercado negro cuatro veces más baratos
que en las farmacias Este es un caso
típico de falsificación
falso un medicamento cuyo ingrediente
activo es la ciproptadina
como pueden ver cambiaron el nombre y le
pusieron
antipalúdicos antibióticos analgésicos
en el mercado se puede encontrar todo
tipo de medicamentos
este negocio siempre ha sido visto como
un negocio mortal venden muerte es lo
único que venden con el mal uso el feto
y las mujeres embarazadas pueden estar
en peligro
también hay un gran riesgo de
insuficiencia renal
las personas que hacen parte de la
asociación de pacientes en hemodiálisis
y con insuficiencia renal conocen muy
bien el precio de los medicamentos que
salvan sus vidas
todo esto se debe a la Pobreza
cuando no puedes pagar el medicamento
adecuado en la farmacia tienes que
recurrir a los vendedores ambulantes Y
eso puede crear todo tipo de problemas
la aduana senegalesa que lleva a cabo
operaciones en las fronteras del país
afirmó que el fenómeno estaba
disminuyendo en senegal según la misma
fuente el valor de las incautaciones de
medicamentos falsificados pasó de 41 mil
millones de francos cfa en 2021 a 4.000
millones de francos cfa en 2022 estos
medicamentos falsificados provienen
principalmente de China e India pero
también de Francia y Bélgica según la
oficina de las Naciones Unidas contra la
droga y el delito
la vecina Guinea es uno de los
principales puertos de entrada de
productos falsificados de la región en
los últimos meses las autoridades han
decidido combatir el problema los
servicios especiales han aumentado las
operaciones sobre el terreno el
comisario soropongui y sus hombres
recorren los mercados de la capital no
tardan en identificar a un sospechoso
[Música]
en un día detuvieron a una decena de
vendedores Y cerraron sus farmacias
clandestinas todo un éxito para la
policía
aún queda mucho trabajo por hacer pero
estamos satisfechos con los resultados
que ya hemos obtenido de 100 tiendas
solo cinco o siete venden medicamentos
falsificados había más pero hemos
acabado con ellas hasta ahora es un
éxito sé que vamos a alcanzar nuestros
objetivos la asociación guineana de
farmacéuticos privados nos lo confirmó
según ellos el mercado farmacéutico
ahora está mejor controlado en Guinea
actualmente hay 10 mayoristas que
abastecen el mercado de medicamentos
frente a los 100 que había antes del
comienzo de las operaciones muchos
fueron cerrados tras las inspecciones el
país también está tomando medidas
legales contra los traficantes de
medicamentos falsificados desde finales
de 2021 la corte encargada de investigar
los delitos económicos y financieros se
ocupa de llevar a los delincuentes ante
la justicia
cerca de 31 personas han sido procesadas
por estos delitos de estos siete casos
cinco han sido en su totalidad con
condenas que oscilan
entre los seis meses y los tres años de
prisión según las Naciones Unidas entre
2017 y 2021 más de 600 toneladas de
medicamentos falsificados o de calidad
inferior fueron decomisados en África
occidental en las operaciones llevadas a
cabo por la Interpol para los
especialistas esta lucha debe ir
acompañada de un más fácil acceso del
público a los medicamentos del mercado
legal la única solución para frenar el
flagelo de la falsificación